hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
it's no secret that the automotive
industry is beginning to change when
Tesla started building electric cars
people were at first skeptical electric
cars at the time was slow had a limited
range and just looks straight-up weird
it seemed that Tesla cars were simply
going to be another one of these
but this wasn't to be the case after a
while word began to spread that these
new electric cars drove well had enough
range for daily driving and were quick
before long there was a cult following
of the Tesla Motor Company in the
mid-to-late 2010s
recognition began to grow until the
average Joe knew what a Tesla was when
he saw it on the road as we approached
the end of the 2010s other car companies
have stopped laughing at Tesla and have
realized that electric cars are here to
stay if they don't get it now they'll
soon be missing out on a huge market in
the future in this video we'll take a
look at some of Tesla's competitors
first we should define what should be
considered a competitor for this case
I'm referring to new fully electric cars
from established companies so not
companies like Faraday future lucid
motors or bison or older cars such as
the BMW i3 or Nissen leaf and for this
video we'll be taking a look at the
high-end specs of each competitor
the mission for the ipace is to be the
most refined electric car
according to Jaguars marketing team
anyway for example during the design
phase each car went through eight weeks
of continuous vibration testing the IPAs
features a 90 kilowatt hour battery and
two motors that generate a combined
power of 294 kilowatts and 700 Newton
meters of torque this will propel the
car from zero to 100 kilometers an hour
in 4.8 seconds the eye pace is up to 480
kilometers of range and DC fast charging
will take over 2 hours what makes the
eye pace a little different is its
dimensions with the freedom given by the
absence of a conventional engine a few
changes have been made for starters the
hood of the car is very short and the
cabin has been extended forward so it
stops over the front wheel arch this was
done to give more room for the interior
not even the Moto X or moto s have been
designed with this in mind the estimated
release is mid 2018 starting in a
hundred thousand US dollars for the base
model by 2025 Jaguar wants all of its
new cars produced to be electric in one
form or another as Porsche just trying
to one-up Tesla or is this just
something they want to do to just keep
improving their brand I think it's
interesting that we're finally seeing
larger automakers getting into electric
drive for a long time we've been hearing
about the promise of electric vehicles
but now we're finally actually beginning
to see them the Porsche mission II is
the quickest of the bunch claiming zero
to 100 kilometers now in under 3.5
seconds but still a ways off the 2.5
seconds achieved by Tesla's T 100 D
model the mission e will get to 200
kilometers an hour in less than 12
seconds and has a top speed of 250
kilometers an hour to keep the
acceleration going strong all the way to
the top speed - speed gearboxes will be
used Stephan work bulk head of the
project confirmed that the mission EU
have computer blended braking where the
brake pedal is a request for braking
rather than an actual link to mechanical
brakes when the pedal is pressed a
computer works out whether it reduces
the disc brakes or regenerative braking
from the motor Porsche claims a 15
minute charge time from 0 to 80 percent
on their specialized charges the company
states that these charges will deliver a
ton
vote with cooling technology to prevent
overheating this energy will of course
come from renewables interestingly by
about 2020 there's going to be a network
of charges across continental Europe
about 120 kilometers apart Porsche is
investing in this network along with
Mercedes BMW Ford an Audi the range of
the electric Porsche is said to be 500
kilometres compared to 630 kilometers
for Tesla's P 100 D but these of course
are EPA ratings so the real world values
will be less obviously the mission e
pricing has been aggressively set to
start at $75,000 the South Korean
company he unday is taking a bold step
into the electric market with their Kona
evie there's two options for the Kona
but the longer range is said to have a
64 kilowatt hour battery pack with an
EPA range of 470 kilometres the car we
use in 150 kilowatt motor to go from 0
to 100 kilometres an hour in a little
over 7 seconds in terms of charging a
1-hour fast DC charge will get you 0 to
80 percent battery life the higher range
he under kona is said to be about 45
thousand US dollars the next competitor
to Tesla is the British company Aston
Martin they've recently revealed that
they're going to make an all-electric
version of their car the rapid e it's
set to enter production in 2019 as part
of the company's second century plan
initiative the rapid EU will have six
hundred kilowatts of power in an
all-wheel-drive format and 320
kilometers of range acceleration figures
haven't been given yet but we can assume
it'll be pretty quick the cost is said
to be two hundred fifty five thousand
dollars and there's going to be a
limited production run of just a hundred
and fifty five cars Aston Martin's
president and CEO dr. Andy Palmer
actually took a dig at Tesla directly
quote most of the people buying a Model
S are buying it fully loaded they're not
limited by their cash they're limited by
the offer we're looking to those people
looking for something above Tesla that
consumer probably isn't looking for
ludicrous mode our offer will have very
credible acceleration equal to a
gasoline Aston Martin but you'll be able
to drive the car rapidly all the way
around nur and
without a derating or Konkan out on you
end quote and shots fired
Aston Martin is teaming up with the
Chinese firm Lee Eco to develop the
electric car Mercedes is also getting in
on the action with their new car the EQ
the German automaker says that its
battery capacity is over 70 kilowatt
hours with a range of about 450
kilometers as for power
Mercedes says that the EQ is equipped
with two electric motors on the front
and rear axles for a total combined
power output of 300 kilowatts
the automaker claims that this will
drive the car from 0 to 100 kilometres
an hour in under five seconds the
pricing starts of 76 thousand US dollars
and the car is set to be arriving in
2019 Aldi also has their sights set on
an electric future starting with their a
Tron Quattro SUV the company says that
the e-tron Quattro has around 442
kilometers of range on a 95 kilowatt
hour battery pack the all-electric SUV
is equipped with three electric motors
for a total output of 320 kilowatts
pushing the car from 0 to 100 kilometers
an hour in 4.8 seconds DC fast charging
will load up the battery in just 50
minutes the car will start at $100,000
in Germany but International pricing is
currently unknown the new all-electric
Aldi is set to be coming in late 2018 so
as you can see the competition for Tesla
is heating up in the all-electric space
no matter the outcome this is ultimately
a good thing the industry has been
forced to move and in the long run
consumers win but with all of that being
said there's something that Tesla has
that the others don't
the Tesla brand name if public sentiment
remains the same after the model 3 snags
currently Tesla stands for something
they're far and away the leader when it
comes to all-electric vehicles and they
have a vision that goes with that but
ultimately only time will tell who will
be the leader in electric cars in the
future so all in all this is some great
stuff we are witnessing the first major
change in the order industry in a
hundred years
and is strongly looking like the 2020s
will be an electric decade anyway thanks
for watching if you've just stumbled
across this channel feel free to
subscribe this has been two Gege and
you've been watching cold fusion and
I'll catch you again soon for the next
video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
[Music]